and i'm afraid i'm going to have to
leave at that point i have another
interview coming along
thank you so much professor
do you mind answering question 21 before
you go the last one 21 it's william
patterson 21 william patterson because
we spoke about wittgenstein before so
i'd be interested to know his thoughts
on kripkenstein's
problem of the rule following paradox
well actually
i've written about it about 35 years ago
but the essential point is
a misunderstanding
of the no true notion
of rule and rule following
that is pervasive
in the philosophical literature
extreme and wittgenstein
kripke took it over
it's just a misunderstanding of the
rules of the notion rule of language
so the model that's basically used is
something like
traffic signals
stop on red you know
don't turn left on red
that's a rule
that we're aware of
and that we can think about and follow
or we can violate you can go through a
red light okay
rules of language aren't like that at
all
so this
let's take a concrete example
say
john stole
many books from the library
okay
many books were stolen from the library
both of them can mean
that the library should have more gourds
so that people won't be stealing books
from it
just a lot of books that john is
stealing
suppose i say
many books are easy to steal from the
library
it doesn't have that meaning
many books mean some specific books
maybe the
the books on biology
those are easy to steal
totally different meaning
well that
we know that
and we know it following rules
the rules are unconscious
can't introspect into them
they're only beginning to be understood
in fact turns out an
intricate
interaction of
principles of computational efficiency
and
certain properties of language interact
to yield these results
those are rules of language
kind of like the rules of vision
let's say uh
you get a couple of
stimulations on your retina from
static eye movements and you see a
person okay that's following rules
that's what the rules of language are
like they're just parts of theories of
explaining the nature of
uh in this case our language system
that's not what fittgenstein had in mind
that's not what kripke had in mind
so the kind of problems they raised just
don't arise
they're talking about some other kind of
system that has nothing to do with
language vision or other biological
properties and that's pervasive in
philosophy of language
just as
the assumption that there's a notion of
reference is pervasive
and it's very it's leading in all the
wrong directions in my opinion so i
don't i simply don't think these
questions arise
thank you sir have a great day
yup
take care
you